all right mr. Jason Derulo good to see
I'm good
you brought you just brought it to rum
tum tugger
all right did you enjoy the process oh
my goodness it was incredible yeah you
know it was it's my first film you know
so to bring back the acting side it felt
good
you know I was a theater kid I went to
college for theater so yeah it's just
you know bringing that guy back it was
amazing that's so great yeah because it
definitely it has a theatrical sense to
it I mean this cats originated as a play
right but you definitely get that
beautiful blend of film and a musical
obviously and in the movie format so it
was so cool though I loved it oh good
good but how do you feel like being a
performer on stage in a live setting
really helped aid you through the
process of filming the movie musical
Cats
um well obviously singing and dancing
for a living it helps you know it's cuz
I didn't have to really prepare it for
the song at all it's not like I was like
slight work right right Oh singing and
dancing is what you do together you do
it so well so it's like trying to figure
out now it's not dancing to be flies
dancing for a purpose so you know I'm
gonna come this to this side because I
need to get to this specific place so I
need to you know I have an action so
it's like marrying those two worlds
together it's like a this like a very
different thing yeah and you're also a
character not only any character you're
a cat yeah you know so what was it like
were there anything was there anything
that posed like an awkwardness or
difficulty in creating this cat-like
persona I think my biggest difficulty
was bringing myself
because I mean I'm just such a upright
person got good posture yeah you know
it's how I was always told like
successful people have better posture so
like my whole life I just kind of walked
on my chest stuff okay while you get to
chest up I was like that's just high and
broke yes so like to bring myself to be
more inner you even make that little
cool Jason everything but did you learn
that in your cat behavioral school cat
behaviorist cool I love that isn't that
what it was called I just call it cat
school and I call the cat
teacher - cat lady but yeah cat school
was incredible
you know just learning to embody the cat
and the mannerisms and all that stuff
just kind of getting all the information
but I think the the most beneficial time
was the time behind by myself which was
a lot of time in the mirror even more
than usual and uh just filming myself
yeah so watching yourself is I think the
best teacher because you know what
you're doing and how it feels to do it
right and how it feels to do it right
right because you're hearing everything
that you need to do then you're putting
it you're putting it into practice in
front of the mirror and then self
critiquing social justice and respect of
it okay this cast next level sane so is
there anyone in the cast that you were
just in all of her maybe you weren't I
think I'm in awe of everybody we cast
even all the dancers there's confetti in
here we're so excited for cash I thought
it was a kangaroo well there is a scene
with cockroaches in there's no berries
or something right um but so this cat
OMG making it rain up in here for this
cast ends a next level so who were you
in all of yeah I mean in awe of
everybody honestly I mean the cast is is
insane
even down to the dance they're some of
the best dancers in the world
so between between scenes you know
you're seeing people do the most
unbelievable things I've ever seen it
jumping and flipping off table is doing
just did you have to one-up and show
what you can do um you know I dunno I
kind of kept it in a pocket not it was
it's incredible I mean you've got some
of the best dancers and also the best
singers in the world best musicians in
the world and you kind of put them all
together and there's like this insane
melting pot even as racially right just
it's just so multicultural so I think
this movie is just so inclusive and
that's the point of the movie as well
they felt the storyline of you know
inclusion communities I think it was a
beautiful thing so it's something that
obviously was happening behind the
camera but in front of it as well yeah I
had you seen cats before you had taken
on the role yeah so I was a musical
theater kid yeah and studying theater
the cats is one of the biggest musicals
of all time so yeah so definitely one of
the study but I never said I think that
role is perfect for me never not one
time but it ended up being perfect
because I needed my first look to be a
bridge between music and and film
first-look and taking on film yeah yeah
acting side yeah I think this was
perfect it was not too much it was not
overbearing I feel like it's like the
perfect bridge for me sure it's so hard
to believe that this is technically your
first film because you've been in films
but as a performer as Jason Derulo not
like as a character is way different
totally different you know so it's neat
to see you in this setting did it take
any kind of like coercing or talking you
into playing this character oh no I was
I was all the way in so I came in late
to the
process so I knew director obviously I
knew he was in it's like a dream team
right I mean it's probably one of the
more star-studded movies you know ever
so yeah I was dying to be part of it
such a good now response the first
trailer everyone seemed to have an
opinion
mmm-hmm so what did you make of that
first trailer honestly when I first seen
the first trailer I don't know if it was
my bias but I was blown away by it and I
remember being in the gym and I was like
just chills down my spine like the whole
night and you know I it kind of brought
me back all the way to the beginning of
my music career when I was you know
first hear my songs on the radio and you
know those those same feelings that I
was getting at that point you know the
nerves you know people actually seeing
him for the first time you know dog it
all kind of came back and snapped in for
me but yeah like you said there was a
lot of talk about it and I think it the
polarizing response is what you want in
anything you know you want people to
have to get aroused by something you
know and to me you can either take the
criticism and you know change some
things if you want or you can you know
just roll with with the vision that you
had but I think it's all positive in the
end and I think no cats is like the most
talked about someone else okay that's
well said you know and it's always good
when people talk right sure and I also
find that when something is so it's
world-renowned this is a play that so
many people have seen finding theaters
it's one of the longest-running in
theaters so there's bound to be some
criticism
you guys said it very very thank you
that being said to create this digital
fir that we see on screen it took CGI so
what were those CGI suits like for you
so it was like being naked pretty much
but like not in a good way it's like
naked in a bad way
yeah so like it like it held you in like
the weird areas and in some areas it was
loose you know I'm saying so like in the
stomach area was like a loose here huh
and it was like tight in like other
areas but it's just not not flattering
but you felt like everybody and you're
like I've been working real hard in the
gym it's like yeah let's get loose like
right here on my on my upper back so my
waist looks looks yes that's great
though is all naked yeah suppose
everywhere you see balls and bulges
everyone well that's that's a well we
got very close oh yes I'd say you did
for short now speaking of suits you were
in a suit recently on the old Graham
yeah and it was going viral did you
think that picture would warrant that
sort of reaction I promise you I didn't
when I was posting it that morning did
you see this picture that you posted
before this no okay I mean like you just
you know some people say I was just an
accidental poster you know what you're
oh no I know I knew is that it was a
thirst trap picture but I didn't I
didn't think when I posted it that it
was gonna be my most liked photo in that
first couple hours no I'm saying I
didn't think it was gonna like be no
take it down from the grant money think
he was gonna like cause this much third
like I mean come on when I was posting
it in the morning I was like oh yeah
woman might like this one yeah but I
wasn't like yo this is about to be crazy
post no no but it was a lot of fun I had
a ton of fun that week
talking about it because you did you had
to talk about it for a hot second so
hopefully the gram won't be taking down
any pictures of you from cats they might
come it was we had we definitely I
definitely had bulges everywhere for
sure
absolutely about to have another viral
degrees so yeah yeah thank you so much
for your time thank you rates first
appearance on the big screen but
hopefully many more to come you have
some more phone calls come in coming all
absolutely I'm actually developing my
own film and I'm actually working on one
with Sandra Jackson yeah
[Music]